people have started to see you know
whatever seems to happen with the real
economy
stock prices go up if the economy's
strong stock price to go up if the
economy is weak
stock prices go up even though wages
never seem to go up so
ordinary people they want to get
involved in this more and more people
especially this year probably because
people are stuck at home and can't do
anything else and often because people
are stuck and can't make a good income
they're at home trying to work out how
can i make money from the stock market
so they're doing what you or i would do
though on the internet they're searching
it and they're often ending up on this
page of reddit which is an internet
messaging board which has they talked
about loads of different stuff on there
but there's a big section which is
basically devoted to talking about the
stock markets financial markets by the
way money
that section's called wall street bets
but there's all these guys they want to
make money from the financial market
how do we do it they're on this place
wall street bets and there's
some guys on there who are very well
informed and they've picked this
company gamestop now gamestop has been
picked out by a number of hedge funds
saying that this is a weak company it's
going to fall
so like we discussed before dead short
sold in stock trying to make money
as it goes down these people on the
internet already
they've realized these guys have sold so
much if we go in
as a big group and buy all of the stock
these short sellers when they
come to time they have to repay their
loans on stock remember they've borrowed
stock yeah
we load all the stock they won't be able
to get any stock and
they will be forced to buy the stock
from us at whatever price we ask for
basically
does that make sense because because
they've they've
they keep buying it even though it's
very very low because the hedge funds
have said this is going nowhere this
company is dead
they buy and buy in the more they buy
the more the price rises and at some
stage the hedge funds have to buy those
stocks back exactly because they
borrowed the stock the hedge fund is
borrowed just like if you borrow you
know a book in the library
you've got to you've got to pay you've
got to give it back these guys have
borrowed it and they sold it but they
need to give it back
so they don't have it ready has gone in
bought all of it so when these guys
come when it comes that they need to
give the stock back they don't have any
stock
and they basically have to pay whatever
these guys already asked for it but
ready are not selling it
they're just insisting that whatever
they'll do they'll buy it and the the
increase has been phenomenal
i think it's gone up i mean it changed
every time you look at it but last time
i looked up it was up
thousand seven hundred percent in two
weeks and it's simply because these guys
aren't refusing to sell they're just
buying pushing up
the idea is you push it up and then
these hedge funds
will be forced to buy at basically
whatever price you are
you